alors autant des ukrainiens la victoire
a désormais possible en tout cas à
portée de main les américains a
toutefois temporisé pour le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken qui
s'exprime et hier il est encore trop tôt
pour juger la contre offensive de kiev
les russes maintiennent des forces très
significative en ukraine estime-t-il
armelle charrier bonjour on décrypte
ensemble ces avancées évidemment sur le
terrain les ukrainiens y croire
forcément la victoire pour eux elle peut
arriver assez vite oui les ukrainiens y
croit et j'allais dire heureusement
parce que la victoire elle est sur leur
terrain et que c'est vrai qu'une
victoire ça aide aussi à avoir le moral
est donc derrière être rassembleur pour
pouvoir mener d'autres opérations
donc ça c'est la nive et la vérité
numéro une par contre ce qui n'est pas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a vu un
ensemble de pays se féliciter de cette
victoire crânienne et donc comme si
demain la victoire totale allez être
remporté c'est pour ça qu anthony
blinken tout de suite mais un veto c'est
à dire qu'ils savent ce qu'ils font les
américains c'est quand même eux qui
livrent des armes qui ont conseillé qui
certainement ont donné du renseignement
aussi aux ukrainiens et disent que y ait
eu une percée qu'elles soient
significatives qu'elles soient
extrêmement importante et qu'elle est
complètement dérouté les russes oui
considéré que derrière après il n'y aura
plus qu'une promenade de santé non parce
que évidemment les russes sont quand
même positionné que même si on l'a
parfaitement compris du côté de kharkiv
ils ont été surpris en revanche du côté
de kherson sa touche à la mer noire la
mer noire c'est un port stratégique là
ils ne veulent pas non plus avoir trop
de défaites donc on n'est pas du tout
sur le fait que les russes s'en vont
demain
les russes parlons-en il ya des fissures
qui apparaissent dans le camp de
vladimir poutine y compris auprès ses
plus fervents soutiens ça c'est quand
même une nouveauté un ce qu'on entend
effectivement c'est un appel à clarifier
de la part de vladimir poutine vous avez
deux types en fait cet appel
soit vous avez des personnes qui vont
être j'allais dire plus classique dans
un rôle d'opposant et où là on a vu des
gens qui sont élus des élus municipaux
députés municipaux saint pétersbourg la
ville qu'on dit la plus proche de
l'europe et moscou qui disent maintenant
il faut qu'ils arrêtent cela dit me
routine il faut qu'il démissionne on est
dans une guerre on s'est fâché avec les
américains on est fâché avec le temps on
va avoir une économie vacillante
donc on appelle à sa démission ça
j'allais dire structurellement c'est
plus classique ils sont opposant
normalement vladimir poutine n'apprécie
pas les opposants c'est qu'il les met en
prison donc il risque gros ils sont
courageux mais voilà il s'exprime de
manière là de l'autre côté vous avez
tout un système de personnes dont
kadirov le fameux tchétchène qu'on avait
vu souvent intervenir on avait vu par
exemple aussi en syrie on a dû
intervenir aussi en ukraine qu'il y ait
beaucoup plus véhéments qui dit les
russes aujourd'hui se font avoir
pourquoi parce qu'ils n'ont pas été
assez virulent et que s'il avait frappé
fortement comme on le fait
habituellement avec énormément de morts
avec énormément de bombardements dans
ces cas là on aurait une reprise
l'ukraine beaucoup plus rapidement donc
passons à l'étape supérieure vladimir
poutine il se sait critiqué par ses deux
axes il est aujourd'hui dans une
politique intérieure un peu difficile on
va voir ce qu'il va décider de l'ukraine
il nous faut un peu de temps
immédiatement il a envoyé en fait des
missiles et des bombardiers frapper des
cibles stratégiques civils qui étaient
des usines qui produisait de
l'électricité et de l'eau en ukraine jeu
ça justement pour casser un peu
l'approvisionnement ukrainien et on va
voir derrière ce qui doit décider ce qui
explique pourquoi est-ce que évidemment
anthony blinken fait aussi attention
voilà une espèce de phases d'entre d'eux
dont il faut aussi se méfier merci
beaucoup armelle pour le décryptage